When editing CSS in
DevTools, you can now easily
increment or
decrement values using
some new shortcuts we've added.
In the sources pane, you
can use Alt-Up or Alt-Down
to increment or decrement
by a value of 1.
You can also use
Alt- Page Up or Page
Down to increment or
decrement by a value of 10.
Now, let's say that you love
working in the elements pane.
Well, you're probably used
to inspecting an element
and then going to
the styles pane
to actually go play
around with values.
Well, you can go and find
the property to work with.
And similar to what
you're used to,
you can still use
the Up and Down keys
to increment or decrement
by a value of 1.
You can also now
increment by a value of 10
or decrement using
Shift-Up or Shift-Down.
And using Shift-Page
Up or Shift-Page Down
you can increment or
decrement by a value of 100.
And finally, for those
ultra-specific properties
you can use Alt-Up and Alt-Down
to increment or decrement
by a value of 0.1.